Director:
All right, check the gate, guys.
I'll go on three?
Director:
Three, two, one, action!
♪♪
David S. Goyer:
Foundation is the greatest
science fiction work of all time.
♪♪
It's a story of ideas and they
are bold ideas.
♪♪
David S. Goyer:
The visual effects are really
cutting edge.
David S. Goyer:
We're going to see things that
we haven't ever seen in a series before.
♪♪
Chris MacLean:
It was a huge collaborative
effort.
Chris MacLean:
It was a thousand people working
on the show to get it finished,
just from a visual effects
perspective.
(Ship engines noise)
Rory Cheyne:
We had so many different minds
working on this project.
It was a real global effort to
get it designed and built and
shot, for sure.
♪♪
Ian Hunter:
These days it's mostly digitally
done.
Ian Hunter:
But, in the case of foundation,
we're actually going to
Ian Hunter:
build miniature models of
some of the spacecrafts
Ian Hunter:
and some of the locations
and then integrate them into the
visual effects.
♪♪
Ian Hunter:
We start with concept art,
turning it into a digital model.
Ian Hunter:
We can then translate that
digital model into a file
Ian Hunter:
that we can use to 3-D print.
So we're taking the digital
asset and turning it into a
physical asset.
♪♪
Ian Hunter:
We're shooting things physically
like, blowing things up in the
cloud tanks
Ian Hunter:
or shooting our miniatures
against an LED screen.
♪♪
Ian Hunter:
Photographing it with a motion
control cameras.
Ian Hunter:
We're taking different methods
of doing visuals,
trying to get every physical
aspect we can.
♪♪
Bart:
Whenever we approach science
fiction,
we always want it to feel
grounded.
Like exploring the look and
style of the costumes.
Bart:
We're looking at like desert
societies and Inuit societies.
♪♪
Kurt:
You have these different
characters coming from different
Kurt:
worlds, it's easier to look at
those characters and think,
Kurt:
"where are they coming from?"
Like Gaal came from Synnax,
which is a water planet.
♪♪
Bart:
Each world, we took what their
environment was,
for design choices to help make
our Foundation universe look
completely original.
♪♪
Alfred Enoch:
You have characters coming from
all sorts of
different worlds, different
classes.
Alfred Enoch:
They'll dress different and
they'll sound differently.
Phara:
(Speaking Anacreon)
Fionnuala Murphy:
Most languages have different
patterns.
Something that would make them unique,
stand out.
♪♪
Fionnuala Murphy:
People from Anacreon, these are
warrior like,
Fionnuala Murphy:
So they're blunt, they're hard
headed
Fionnuala Murphy:
They just come out with it.
(Speaking Anacreon)
Fionnuala Murphy:
The other language Thespis,
they're a bit more laid back.
Fionnuala Murphy:
So that gives certain qualities
to the languages.
That sets them apart.
♪♪
David Kob:
With Foundation, we're trying to
do for science fiction
David Kob:
what Game Of Thrones did for
fantasy.
David Kob:
Which is present a fully
realized world
with a level of sophistication
that's never been seen on
television before.
Lou Llobell:
Seeing the work that everyone
puts in
Lou Llobell:
and how much love has gone into
it,
it's going to be one heck of
a show.
♪♪